we now are learning more and more about
what was actually
a coordinated plan
to
send
fraudulent electors
in multiple states to washington dc to
try to steal the election from joe biden
as a reminder joe biden won the election
in november of 2020. there was a
concerted effort made across a number of
different areas to try to steal the
election by donald trump
we now know that rudy giuliani was at
the helm of a fake elector plot in seven
states rudy may now have legal problems
as a result
cnn reporting washington i'm sorry trump
campaign officials led by giuliani
oversaw efforts in december of 2020 to
put forward illegitimate electors from
seven states that trump lost
according to three sources with direct
knowledge of the scheme
the sources said members of trump's
former campaign team
were far more involved than previously
known a core tenet of the broader plot
to overturn joe biden's victory on
january 6th giuliani and allies
coordinated the nuts and bolts of the
process on a state-by-state level the
sources told cnn one source said there
were multiple planning calls between
trump campaign officials and republican
state operatives and that giuliani
participated in at least one call the
source also said that the trump campaign
lined up the supporters to fill elector
slots secured meeting rooms and state
houses for the fake electors to meet on
december 14th and circulated drafts of
fake certificates that were ultimately
sent to the national archives
trump and some of his top advisors
publicly encouraged the alternate
electors scheme in pennsylvania georgia
michigan arizona wisconsin nevada and
new york
but behind the scenes giuliani and trump
campaign officials
actively choreographed the process the
source said they were going to try to
dump in big massive dumps fake
electors to vote for uh trump instead of
biden we already knew this remember that
we actually talked about this um
not long ago
one of the republican lawmakers who
signed the fake arizona document with
state representative jake hoffman he was
confronted about this and said who
organized this who told you to show up
that day
and sign this fraudulent document he ran
away from reporters remember we looked
at this clip
when bram wants to ask a real question
happy to have a conversation with him
okay thank you sir
richard
i had a couple things
that being one of yours
i'm asking you that question wonder what
authority did you find yourself as an
elector so in unprecedented times
unprecedented action is occurred there
is no case law there's no precedent that
exists
as to whether or not a
an election that is currently being
litigated in the courts
has do standing which is why we felt it
appropriate to provide congress and the
vice president with
dueling opinions did you have direction
from anybody in doing this
was it you eleven yourself to doing this
or did someone give you advice on the
matter in which you can do it
so i'm simply i was one of the electors
right i'm not in charge of the elector
so you would need how did you hear it
you you wouldn't drew here you would
need to ask the party to hear them how
did you hear about the plan was you just
told to be someone you would need to ask
the party chair but you're the you're
the person who received the call you
showed up right how did you know to show
up that day so as i said you can go
ahead and ask the party chair the
logistics of it ask her how you got a
phone call to go somewhere you're
welcome to talk to them about this you
do not know how you arrived at a place
thank you i i appreciate your time you
really know how you got a call have a
great one the other questions
so this needs to be taken completely
seriously
if at the individual level you fill out
a fake ballot sometimes you go to jail
we've seen that happen at the individual
level they tried to steal the whole
election and all of a sudden it's like
well are we gonna do anything about that
might we file charges it's a federal
crime to interfere with the mail but if
you're the postmaster general you can
sabotage the whole system make it more
difficult to vote by mail and there's no
repercussions it's common
that at the street level things are
punished
and then at the structural level they
are not
now
all of this goes back to one of the many
prongs that they had in place to try to
steal the election one prong was that if
there are states that they just won't
accept were won by joe biden
on january 6
or december 14th depending on how the
plan went instead of sending only the
democratic electors to dc what
republicans wanted to do was send an
alternate slate of electors and they
wanted to force mike pence when it came
time for arizona's votes to be counted
for example for mike pence to say
because the results of arizona seem
fake i mean i don't even know how you
say it and not sound like a complete
authoritarian clown
instead of accepting the democratic
votes from arizona we have these other
what's the number seven 14 i don't
remember these other electors from
arizona how do you vote we vote for
trump that was the plan now that plan
failed but understand that if they had
had
different people in place at the state
level
if trump had had the generals with him
as was warned now a couple weeks ago by
retired military generals the outcome
could have been different it's really
great that it failed given how badly it
could have gone but this was a plan for
a complete coup including possibly
declaring a state of emergency was being
floated trying to get the military to
enforce a different winner
fake electors flipping states by
pressuring secretaries of state they are
going to try it again
we just saw they don't even know joni
ernst asked what are three things you
would do she has nothing so they're not
trying to win on policy
they are going to try this again and we
have to be ready for it and we'll have
more on this on our instagram
find us on instagram at david pakman
show
one of our sponsors is kamikoto making
elegant high-end beautiful japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan i've been a
big fan of japanese kitchen knives for a
long time they have some great
advantages when you look closely at a
kamikoto knife you see the quality of
the iron work they only use japanese
steel every knife comes in a perfect
heavy duty ash wood box makes storage
really easy it looks great in your
kitchen or drawer the balance of the
knives is just amazing i've been using
them for everything every knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee on their
website you can see the complete list of
chefs at michelin star restaurants who
use kamikoto and through this
partnership they're doing with us
kamikoto is giving you 50 off on top of
their other special offers just go to
camikoto.com
pacman and use the code pacman for 50
off the link is down below